bonjour mercredi 20 juin patrick dils à
une semaine devant lui pour convaincre
la cour d'assises dès mineurs de la
marne de son innocence son nouveau
procès a commencé ce matin à huis clos
il avait été condamné pour le meurtre de
deux enfants et puis il y a eu un fait
nouveau la présence sur les lieux du
crime de francis heaulme qualifié de
tueur en série valérie ermite raymond
chape l'art pour le rappel de cette
affaire c'est le grand jour pour patrick
dils quinze ans après les faits douze
ans après sa condamnation à perpétuité
l'adolescent qu'il était aujourd'hui
devenu un adulte va se battre une
deuxième fois devant une cour d'assises
et clamer son innocence depuis 14 ans
qu'on se bat on pense que la justice
soit faite de loire de blanchir nos
pieds seconde parce qu'avec tous les
proches qui lui pense qu il va être
innocenté aujourd'hui un procès
extraordinaire qu'a réclamé par la cour
de révision qui a jugé qu'il y avait un
doute raisonnable sur la culpabilité de
patrick dils
un doute que n'ont jamais partagé les
familles des victimes
nous verrons bien à lundi si oui ou non
on ne m'apporte quelque chose ou pas à
ce procès il n'apporte rien s'ils
n'apportent rien je tiens à dire que
pour moi la culpabilité patrick dils ne
fait aucun doute aux mains francis
heaulme tueur en série notoire sera
convoqué lundi prochain comme témoin car
c'est sa présence sur le lieu du crime
qui a tout fait basculer aux mains
auteur de plusieurs meurtres étaient
tous frais de ces voies de chemin de fer
le 28 septembre 86 le jour où alexandre
et cyril âgé de 8 ans furent découverts
morts tués à coups de pierres près des
voies ferrées
à l'époque patrick dils alors âgé de 16
ans est arrêté passe aux aveux avant de
se rétracter mais en vain il sera
condamné à la perpétuité en 1989
aujourd'hui patrick dils est bien décidé
à s'expliquer expliqué sur ses aveux qui
dit-il lui ont été suggérées par la
police en début d'audience l'accusé a
demandé à ce que son procès soit public
pour je cite que tout le monde sache la
vérité mais la cour d'assises de reims
vient de refuser car patrick dils certes
aujourd'hui âgé de 31 ans était mineure
au moment des faits le procès se
déroulera donc à huit clos sans public
et sans journalistes